the scary movie where you started
getting bruises all over your body
during the filming that was the
conjuring that movie's awesome
i'm a big conjuring fan yeah that movie
is so
[ __ ] up that movie messed me up for my
whole life how do you explain
that all of a sudden during the filming
of the movie mysterious bruises show up
on you
all right okay let me just let's jump
into this story because this story
it is so it's so weird and this is truly
like the
root of why i'm so scared of that movie
um so you know in the story when the mom
gets possessed she gets all these
bruises on her
and so during the filming of those
particular scenes i started having a lot
of bruises show up in my body
in bizarre places like on my stomach on
my chest like
what and so the makeup ladies thought i
was stealing their fake bruises and like
playing a joke on them and i was like uh
why would i do that i'm not doing that
that's crazy they didn't believe me they
try to take
my real bruises off with like rubbing
alcohol and oil and i'm like i'm telling
you
i'm not lying i went to the doctor i got
a couple blood tests because
they told me it looked like it could
potentially be
early signs of leukemia i was so freaked
out
i mean what i'm by the way i'm 12. like
what doctor says that to a 12 year old
what kind of bedside manner is that
so i get these blood tests all of a
sudden i'm told that i have this
blood thinning condition called itp
where basically
most of my red platelets drained from my
body mysteriously
i'd never had a blood problem in the
past i've never had a blood problem
since then
i i no one in my family has that so
um i i was at risk of needing a blood
transfusion
and they were like scared to even let me
work and because if i like touched
something i could get a bruise there was
weird and so i had to go to the hospital
every day
twice a day before and after work to get
my blood taken to check my platelets and
to try and rebuild my platelets on my
own by
taking a lot of iron and they were just
creeping up for the duration of the
shoot
uh shooting finishes i go home and i
still have to keep up with this [ __ ]
and then when i came home my platelets
were completely fine like i was back up
to the normal numbers
and i've never since had a trace of that
disorder so no wonder you're freaked out
by
are you kidding me i was just like you
know what this is it for me like i've
had a good run i'm 12 years old i'm just
gonna
you know get killed by a ghost now i
don't know we'll see what happens
that is such a weird story and no one
has an explanation for it
i feel so freaked out by it it's like so
scary
the other day i looked up a photo of the
the witch from the movie
because that's the real name of the
woman and i felt so
scared typing her name into my web
browser i was like she's watching me
she's going to kill me by the way
who is that person behind you this oh my
god
my heart just like jumped out i was just
trying to scare you yeah it worked it
really worked